معنى من هيروشيما مراسله الجزيره وجد وقفي
وايضا مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي وجد ما
ابعاد الرسائل السياسيه
لقاده دول السبع في هذه القمه
نعم ربما الابرز هي الرسائل التي خرجت
بدايه لروسيا وثانيا للصين فيما يتعلق
بروسيا كانت هناك رساله وحده من قبل قاده
مجموعه السبع فيما يتعلق بتقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا المالي الانساني الاقتصادي
والعسكري طالما استغرق ذلك من وقت وكان
مسؤول رفيع امريكي قد قال نامل ان تكون
الصين ترى كل هذا الدعم من اجل اوكرانيا
لصد العدوان الوحشي بحسب وصفه الروسي على
اراضيها
وان تقوم باتخاذ موقف بناء على صعيد
المساعده في انهاء الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا على اعتبار بحسب المسؤول
الامريكي ان لدى الصين تاثير كبير على
روسيا وبان بامكانها المساعده لاقناعها
على انهاء هذه الرئيس بايدن قبل قليل قال
ان بامكان روسيا انهاء الحرب اليوم اذا
ارادت لانها هي التي بدات هذه الحرب ولكنه
اكد في المقابل على ان الولايات المتحده
ابلغت حلفائها بان الدعم مستمر لاوكرانيا
الى حين احلال السلام الذي ينشده
الاوكرانيون وهو سلام شامل بمغادره جميع
القوات الروسيه الاراضي الاوكرانيه حزمه
المساعدات الجديده الامريكيه ايضا قابلها
العقوبات امريكيه عقوبات من الاوروبيين
عقوبات من اليابان عقوبات من جميع الدول
مجموعه السبع جديده على روسيا لتقوض
الموارد الماليه لروسيا وايضا قدراتها
العسكريه فيما يتعلق بالصين ايضا جلال
اسمحلي هناك قضيه مهمه الرئيس بايدن قال
ان تفاهما بين جميع قاده
السبع مجموعه السبع وكذلك رباعيه الكواد
الامنيه التي تضم الولايات المتحده
واستراليا والهند واليابان على انه في حال
اتخذت الصين
عملا احاديا ضد تايوان فانه سوف يكون هناك
رد قبل هذا الاعلان للرئيس بايدن كان هناك
حديث عن وجود خلافات بين الاوروبيين وبين
الولايات المتحده واليابان فيما يتعلق
بالصين وتايوان الاوروبيون يريدون مواقفا
اقل تشددا لكن واضح ان رئيس بايدن حصل هنا
في هيروشيما على ضوء اخطر لكي يقول بان
هناك تفاهم على انه سيكون هناك رد من قبل
جميع هذه الدول موحده في حال الصين اتخذت
فعلا عسكريا ضد الت